hello and welcome to Rochford district
matters the magazine produced by the
council for its residents this is the
autumn 2013 edition in this edition are
articles on who helps with flooding a
warning about payday lenders dial 111
for medical assistance our new chief
executive the annual report for 2012-13
how smoke alarms save lives and much
more but we'll begin with some good news
for one of our residents golden ticket
found watch the district resident
Barbara Spratt is the lucky winner of
our recycling competition message in a
bottle Barbara from whole bridge won the
competition by putting the special
golden ticket from the last edition of
Rockford district matters into her
normal glass bottle recycling she was
awarded her 50 pound prize by the
council's recycling mascot Max the
dragon to show just how good you are at
recycling according to provisional
figures the district is on target to be
the best in England according to
letsrecycle.com rocked the district
council tops the league table in
recycling composting and reuse for
England in 2012-13 we will find out if
the prediction is right when the
official figures are released by the
Department for environmental food and
rural affairs known as death rock in
November and there is a photograph of
Barbara Spratt mex the dragon and Barry
Saunders the street scene manager the
Citizens Advice Bureau are warning
residents about the perils of payday
lenders payday lenders are damning
people to debt by failing to carry out
checks to make sure borrowers can afford
to repay the loan says Rochford and
rayleigh Citizens Advice Bureau you
figures from the National Citizens
Advice payday loan tracker found
sixty-five percent of people did not get
asked about their financial situation
leading to seven in ten not being able
to pay back the loan this goes the gates
pledges the payday loan industry made in
its customers charter launched on
96th of November 2012 the figures also
found that customers who won't ask
affordability questions and had
repayment problems were further let down
by lenders as 16-7 did not offer to
freeze interest in charges when the
borrower agreed repayments 71 percent
did not explain how much it will cost to
extend the loan eighty-four percent did
not treat people sympathetically during
the same time period over 11,000 people
sought online help from citizens advice
about payday loans in the last four
years Citizens Advice Bureau has seen a
tenfold increase in pay day loans for
advice on maximizing your income see our
helpful guide on how to spend less on
WWI advice vou que su marie district
manager of Rochford and raelia citizens
advice bureau said day in day out we see
people battling with payday loan debts
many have been able to take out a loan
despite it being quite clear from their
finances that they'll struggle to pay it
back it's very disappointing that payday
lenders are not asking borrowers about
their financial situation to see if they
are able to repay the loan especially
given that they vowed to do so payday
lenders need to take their pledge to
treat people fairly seriously by and
making sure they are check the loan is
affordable and help those who struggle
to pay back the loan if you are having
problems repaying a play-day low please
contact Rochford and rayleigh CA b for
advice on 08 double 44 double 70 808
volunteering is a great way to meet new
people and gain new skills as well as
give something back to the local
community the involvement of volunteers
is often vital to the smooth running and
operation of a community group or
charity revs accredited Volunteer Center
provides support to those looking to
volunteer and for the organization's
projects and community activities
looking for volunteers
it's entirely up to you how much time
you can offer although some
organizations require a minimum time
commitment but please remember any time
you can give as a volunteer is valued
what can you do well there are a range
of opportunities to choose from such as
befriending social clubs driving
fundraising office and admin work sport
and a whole lot more why not give us a
call to find out more or email us you
can also visit the national volunteering
database ww do it and that's do hyphen
dot org revs Volunteer Center uploads
all of its latest volunteering
opportunities to this site when on the
homepage of the doit website just search
for your nearest volunteer centre by
putting in your postcode and from there
you'll be able to view all of our
available opportunities we look forward
to hearing from you and that's ravs
really rochford and district association
for voluntary service their addresses
105 a high street rayleigh essex ss6 7qa
their website is www RAV sog UK you can
email them volunteering at ravs co dot
UK and you can telephone them on Oh 1268
double 727 96 revs is once again running
laptop courses which aim to help the
over 25s learn computing skills laptop
can help you with the beginners computer
course a home visits and a link to
Rochford computer club all in a relaxed
atmosphere among the skills the course
teaches are how to visit websites that
you've seen on television how to send
email with photos attached how to
transfer photos from cameras to
computers and learn about internet
shopping
the contact number is 0 1 2 6 8 double
seven to 796 who helps with flooding the
Met Office will give warnings these are
circulated through the media file
weather forecasts if the rain is likely
to lead to flooding related to rivers
the environment agency will issue
warnings their responsibility extends to
other critical ordinary water courses
which includes many of the main streams
and some main ditches most ditches are
the responsibility of the landowner
Essex County Council is the lead local
flood authority and has a role in
overseeing the management of local flood
risk including one ground water flooding
caused when heavy or prolonged rainfall
makes the ground water table rise above
its normal level to surface water that's
rainfall runoff flows from or over
surfaces such as roads roofs and patios
that cannot easily absorb water three
ordinary water courses streams and
ditties channels which cannot contain
large volumes of surface water runoff
during or after heavy rain anglian water
have responsibility for the removal of
wastewater via the sewage system sand
bags have a limited effect in protecting
properties during flash flooding as they
need to be stored on the premises in
advance of the event they can be
obtained from commercial outlets and
sand purchased from builders merchants
the emergency services will respond in
the best way they can to protect life
during an incident flooding on the roads
is the responsibility of essex highways
where people have to leave their
properties the responsibility from
rehousing social housing tenants lies
with the relevant Housing Association
those in private homes will need to make
their own arrangements but would look to
their insurance companies to assist
there may be cases where people become
homeless in which case they would be
helped by Rochford district council
where large numbers of people have been
evacuated the council will use its
emergency arrangements to provide
temporary on
dation and care rochford District
Council will work with its residents
during the recovery phase to provide
appropriate services for example the
removal of flood contaminated carpets
and furniture and advice on possible
council tax relief a flood action
planning floods can happen anywhere at
any time caused by rising groundwater
overwhelmed drainage systems hillside
Iran off due to southern heavy rain as
well as flooding from rivers and the sea
even if you have miles from the coast or
a river flooding can affect you prepare
for flooding by following a few small
steps to reduce the impact of flooding
on your home find out if you live in an
area at risk from sea or river flooding
and sign up to flood line direct a free
service that provides warnings direct to
you by phone mobile SMS email or fax
visit WWE fan agency guru K or call 0845
nine double eight double one double
eight for further information make a
flood plan know how to turn off gas
water and electricity supplies have a
flood kit torch wind up radio important
telephone numbers and bottled water
think about what can be moved to a safe
place now photo albums family videos
treasured items think about what you
would want to move to safety if flooding
is forecast for example cars pets and
furniture protect your property from the
flooding while it is impossible to
completely flood proof or property there
are lots of things you can do to reduce
flood damage by preventing or delaying
water entering your property a range of
guys can be found at ww environment
hyphen agency UK or by calling 0845
ninth of late double one double eight to
help you prepare further information and
contacts for information on surveil
weather warnings www Met Office gov UK
087
900 Oh 104 general advice on flood risk
register for flood alerts and warnings
ww environment hyphen agency gov UK 084
598 double one double eight the national
flood forum for downloadable leaflets on
flood protection products and services
wwrd for emoji UK 0 1 2 9 940 3055 essex
highways WWE essex highways or 0845 606
7631 that's for urgent and 24-hour
contact and the association of british
insurers WWE bir Guk Oh 2076 double o
double three double three theatre fun
for the whole family a new monthly
program of professional family theatre
has launched at the mill arts & Events
Center in rayleigh roxford district
council arts development has teamed up
with virgin active to bring some great
touring shows to rayleigh this new offer
for families follows pilot theater
events that took place earlier this year
and a consultation carried out with
local residents the pilot events sold
out quickly and the big messages that
came through the consultation was the
parents and carers wanted fun and
educational entertainment that was local
and affordable the full lineup of shows
through to March 2014 can be found at
WWF a govt UK forward slash arts and
includes Arthur's dreamboat Beauty and
the Beast the sorcerer's apprentice
Sally and the sunflower and the three
Billy thinks tickets wall shows are on
sale now and cost us three pound fifty H
by calling what's the district councils
customer services
0170 2318 191 during office hours only
watch villain council point sports
awards 2013 sponsored by virgin active
the sixth annual sports awards ceremony
will take place on Wednesday the 23rd of
October at the mill arts event center in
rayleigh london 2012 bronze medalist
Chloe Rogers will be our guest speaker
and awards will be made in the following
categories sports personality of the
year sponsored by Wells legal solicitors
disability sports personality of the
year sponsored by Walters and Stanton
PLC young sports personality of the year
sponsored by selling an IT community and
educational trust sports club of the
year sponsored by the Essex leopards
basketball club services to sport
sponsored by the co-operative
funeralcare Rochford and castle point
2012 respect warden sponsored by
affinity 1777 thank you to all our
sponsors and to BBC essex for their
support for further information please
go to www k /span woods or phone the
rocks for district counts council
leisure team on 0 1 702 31 8 121
revenues and benefits have been working
hard to update our section of Rochford
district councils website making it
easier for customers to find out about
our services the new pages are
informative user friendly and help
customers to help themselves by visiting
our website you can use our online
services to view your council tax
business rates or housing benefit
accounts you can report a move make
payments sign up for direct debits and
paperless billing and download
application forms and advice leaflets on
the council tax page you can find out
how to use our online services how your
bill is calculated how to pay what
happens if you don't pay what to do if
you're moving
about discounts and exemptions about
local council tax support how to appeal
and how to contact us on the benefits
page you can find out how to use our
online services how to make a claim
about welfare reform changes about
discretionary housing payments about
overpaid Housing Benefit how to report
suspected fraud how to appeal and how to
contact us and on the business rates
page you can find out how to use our
online services how to pay what happens
if you don't pay about moving how to
reduce your bill and how to appeal and
how to contact us council tax discount
for carers the qualifying criteria for a
council tax carers discount changed from
april 2013 if you are providing care to
someone who is not your spouse civil
partner or child under the age of 18 you
may be entitled to claim a discount to
help reduce your council tax bill to
qualify you must be providing care to a
person who is entitled to attendance
allowance the highest or middle rate of
the care component of a disability
living allowance an increased rate of
disablement pension or an increase in
constant attendance allowance and you
must also live in the same property as
the person who you are caring for and
provide care for at least 35 hours a
week on average for more information or
to request an application form called
0170 2318 1 9700 170 2318 198 offering a
helping hand if you're getting council
tax support and are struggling to pay
your council tax we have a dedicated off
of officer laura paul who can offer help
and advice you can call her and I 170
231 80 89 visit her at the council
offices South Street Roger between 830am
and 5 p.m. monday to friday or
request a home visit if you find it
difficult to get out if you are worried
about your financial health visit
www.surgicalscience.com its work and
money bank accounts and credit and debit
cards medical assistants fast when your
child is running a slight temperature
your elderly parent complains of pain or
you developed a nagging earache it's
quite often when your doctors surgeries
closed it may not be a 999 emergency but
you do need to get help or advice fast
what should you do if you live anywhere
in south essex the answer is dial one
easy number you simply need to call 111
the Alexis 111 number allows people to
access health care for any health
problem that is not life-threatening you
can ring the 111 number 24 hours a day 7
days a week 365 days a year the NHS in
south essex wants to reassure residents
that the 111 number is working very well
in our area NHS staff are dealing
quickly and efficiently with a high
volume of calls when patients dial 111
they're put through to highly trained
call handlers supported by experienced
nurses or paramedics they will be
clinically assessed and either given
information or referred directly to the
most appropriate service which can deal
with their injury or illness this may
range from dentist pharmacy or community
service to out of hours GP or in some
cases and ambulance
NHS castlepoint and Rockford clinical
commissioning group Commission's the NHS
111 service for the people of South
Essex dr. Roger Gardiner GP member of
the group and lead clinician for NHS 111
in south essex said we would like to
reassure local people that the service
in south essex is working very well and
has not encountered the problems
described in the national media we are
confident a local service is robust and
able to cope in a timely manner with the
demands placed upon it let me assure
patients that 111 is the number to call
for urgent or out-of-hours medical help
it's never been easier that is spelt bi
in reporting the problem with your bins
has never been easier whatever the day
or time you can now log on to the
council website and let us know of any
issues you are experiencing with your
waste bins if you are being damaged or
missing then log on to www k forward
slash on the line underscore services
forward slash report it and complete the
online form the forms are user-friendly
easy to understand and guide you through
the questions step by step within a
couple of clicks your issue will be
reported and a member of our team will
contact you as soon as they can for more
information about this or any of our
other online forms please contact our
customer services on 0170 2318 one
double one and watch the district
councils love where you live says don't
mess with us to report a street scene
problem go to our website w WR govt UK
forward slash street scene email
customer services at Rochford govt UK or
phone 0170 2318 one double one
Independence Day 2013 the district's
local independent businesses and
shop at my local team joined forces to
celebrate Independence Day on the fourth
of July a national campaign organized by
the National Skills Academy for retail
was launched which enabled shop at my
local to champion the local retailers
who make Rochford districts so special
and unique retailers were encouraged to
say thank you to the local shoppers for
supporting them involving giveaways
discounts and cupcakes in addition to
this retailers from across the district
join together to demonstrate their
community spirit shoppers were
encouraged to buy at least one item from
their local independent retailer shovel
my lobe will run a competition for its
trader members to advertise their
voucher in the echo newspaper the hard
page advert go into a taste of what the
public can receive when they pledge to
shop locally at ww at my local or one
word calm members at the shop at my
local steering group local parish and
town council members and local business
owners are out in force promoting the
local scheme and encouraging shoppers to
pledge their support for local retailers
over 100 people pledge their support on
the fourth of July and now have access
to vouchers latest offers and news items
following the success of Independence
Day we're thinking about what else shop
at my local and local retailers can do
to encourage the public to shop locally
and to promote our shopping areas across
the district ideas for empty shops the
summer edition of Rochford district
matters provided an article regarding
empty shops and asked residents what can
be done to help we've already received
some ideas for improving the situation
pop-up shops where empty shops are used
for a short period art exhibitions
photography displays council surgery
sessions temporary recruitment or
careers fairs showcasing students work
and community events if you have any
other thoughts or suggestions for
contact us at business at Rochford golf
doctor UK small business saturday is a
grassroots campaign that encourages
people to shop local and support small
businesses in their communities both on
the day and beyond Small Business
Saturday in the UK will take place on
Saturday the seventh of December one of
our busiest shopping days of the year
American Express will be supporting the
campaign on this side of the pond as
well and they aren't the only ones the
movement is already growing with backing
from the Federation of Small Businesses
forum for private business the
association of convenience stores the
British Chamber of Commerce and the
association of town and city management
representing hundreds of thousands of
local businesses will be supporting this
and holding events on the day in your
local high streets and shopping areas
why not pop along to join in the fun and
support your local businesses what else
could be due to promote the unique
shopping areas that we have in the
Rockford district if you have any
suggestions please email us at business
at Rochford gov doctor UK our new chief
executive rocks for District Council has
named its successor to the existing
chief executive Paul Warren who will
retire at the end of the year following
a rigorous selection process mr dave who
is currently acting corporate director
of environment culture and transport at
Reading Borough Council was selected
from more than 30 applicants for the
position mr. dave has been at reading
since 2010 he has extensive experience
of managing the delivery of frontline
council services including highways
transport planning environmental housing
arts and heritage prior to joining
reading mr. dave has enjoyed success in
a number of other high-profile roles
with organizations including australe
District Council and Amy facilities
management mr. Dave said I'm really
looking forward to joining Rochford
district councillors chief executive and
working with staff and accounts
to continue to deliver the best possible
services for residents businesses and
visitors right across the district I
know the Rochford district and the
county well as my wife grew up in Essex
and she still has family living here
it's a pleasure to return to Essex where
we can bring up our family mr. Dave is
now expected to join the council in
mid-october before the current chief
executive Paul Warren retires at the end
of December 2013 the annual voter
registration canvassed the register of
electors is published every year
following a canvass of all households in
the district this year the canvas will
start in October look out for the form
coming for your litter box in October
and return it early to avoid receiving a
reminder you must by law respond to the
canvas form and provide the information
asked for you are not automatically
registered even if another department
within the council holds your details
for any other purpose remember you can
only vote in elections and referendums
if your name is on the register of
electors your credit rating can be
affected if you are not registered where
you live some facts about the voter
registration canvas for Rochford
District Council every year at the start
of the canvas we hand deliver over
34,000 registration forms last year we
had to deliver over 15,000 reminder
forms that's the total of nearly 50,000
forms in 2012 canvas is not on the doors
of nearly 7,000 properties that hadn't
returned the form please help us to save
your money by returning your form
promptly if all the details on your form
are correct you can use the free phone
service or the Internet to respond if
you prefer to return your form by post
or you have some changes to make please
make you sure you sign and date the form
and return to us in the prepaid envelope
for further information from the
electoral registration helpline on 0 1
702 318 187 or email elections at
Rochford rqk it's time for you to have
your say
local government is currently facing
some of the most financially challenging
times in recent history which means that
we have to make difficult decisions on
the services and level of service we
provide as we consider next year's
budget we like the views of you as a
resident or business in the district
about what services you would be willing
to see reduced or be charged for for
2014-15 in order to be able to maintain
the authorities expenditure within the
income being received from government
and council tax about 500,000 pounds
worth of savings need to be identified
there is a survey the survey contains
four sections the first section details
leisure and cultural services planning
and development and environmental
services leisure and cultural services
covers the wind Bell leisure premises
woodlands and parks and open spaces
Planning and Development covers economic
development voluntary grants and
community safety environmental services
covers environmental health public
conveniences Street cleansing recycling
collection and communications in this
section you are given the cost of the
service and asked what level of
reduction you would make and your
choices are don't reduce reduce
marginally reduced significantly or
don't know there's also room to give
your comments section 2 asks whether
there are any services that you
currently receive where you'd be willing
to pay a fee in order to avoid further
reductions in service section 3 asks
whether you would be prepared to pay
more council tax if this would avoid
further reduction in services and
section 4 asks about you your sex
ethnicity age etc but you don't have to
answer the
if you prefer not to if you would find
it difficult to use a printed copy of
this survey then please do call Rochford
Council on 0170 2546 366 and they will
be happy to find a way to help you to
have your say all in a day's recycling
lorraine allison from stanbridge hates
to waste anything and reuses recycles
and composts everything she can that is
why she has been nominated as a local
recycling champion with three home
composter business lorraine can compost
her food scraps and garden waste to make
her own compost any additional garden
and food waste goes into her curbside
compostables thin which is green with a
yellow lead and is collected weekly all
food waste can be placed into this bin
including meat fish and bones as they
should not be placed into your own home
compost bin anything that isn't reused
is recycled and Anna rain makes sure she
washes all her bottles cans and food
containers before placing them loose
into her recyclables been electrical
items should not be placed into any of
the three curbside bins broken small
electrical items can be recycled at the
dedicated recycling bank in back lane
car park ruptured at any of the lmb
textile banks throughout the district
and at the essex textiles bank at paul's
lane whole bridge small and large
electrical items and furniture which can
be reused can be collected for free by
the charity hope works they resell items
in their shop and help people who are on
low income hope works can be contacted
on 01 2687 four 32 32 for further
information but else will work with
essex textiles to provide a free
textiles curbside collection service
just call them on 800 787 9071 for more
information and a supply of blue bags
fill the bags with textiles and place
them out for collection on the morning
of your recycle
collection day please do not place the
bags in the bin Lorraine's home is full
of good quality furniture which other
people didn't want even her two dogs are
recycled are you a recycling champion or
do you know anyone that is if so please
get in touch as we'd love to hear your
story that's the district covered a
brand new facility is now available in
whole bridge for residents to take their
old and unwanted small electrical items
for recycling from broken or unwanted
computer keyboards through to old
television remote controls toasters
kettles and hair dryers you can now
recycle lots of small waste electrical
and electronic equipment or we at the
Essex textiles recycling bank located in
Paul's lane car park there are currently
already a number of banks that locations
across the district making whole bridge
the final area to ensure that every part
of the district has access to this
service the Essex textiles bank can now
also accept small electrical items as
well as textiles and shoes residents are
to ensure that we and textile items are
placed in separate bags there is a wee
banking back lane car park rochford and
there are lmb textile banks the code
located at a number of locations across
the district and our harborage residents
have the same opportunity to recycle we
the most important thing is that small
electrical items should not be disposed
of in any of your three curbside bins
please note that we banks do not accept
a computer screens or televisions
Rochford District Council thanked the
hundreds of love rochford district
volunteers by holding a picnic style
presentation at Cherry Orchard jubilee
country park in partnership with
McDonald's the big lunch was held to
celebrate the success of the love
roxford district campaign which focuses
on informing residents about
environmental issues such as litter and
dog fouling the first litter pick took
place in May 2012 and involved
McDonald's sita UK friends of cherry
orchard and Rochford district council
after which subsequent litter picks were
held every month and developed into the
love rochford district campaign since
april 2013 volunteers have given more
than 500 hours of their time and
collected over 200 bags of litter many
more litter picks are planned the event
was attended by the chairman of Rochford
District Council Councillor Barbara
Wilkins who thanked the volunteers and
presented them all with certificates
councillor Wilkins said it's amazing to
see all these young people who have
given up their own time to help click
keep the beautiful district of Rockford
clean and tidy our big lunch is a
celebration of all their hard work and
is a fantastic way to recognize their
achievements and very proud of them all
lunch was provided by mcdonald's
Sainsbury's Asda and the cop who
provided a mouth-watering spread of
healthy snacks drinks and sandwiches a
new campaign launches to help reduce
chewing gum litter roxio District
Council will launch a new campaign in
October with the aim of reducing chewing
gum litter in the local area encouraging
the residents to vinit your way the
council has partnered with the chewing
gum Action Group an organization chaired
by defra and funded by the chewing gum
industry to tackle gum litter in the UK
the campaign now in its eighth year sees
industry working with councils to
develop local initiatives to reduce
chewing gum litter rochford District
Council is among 16 local authorities
taken part in the 2013 activity and is
the only one in Essex the campaign aims
to educate residents about how it is
unacceptable to drop gum onto our
pavements which can result in a fine of
75 pounds for residents clearing chewing
gum is a very costly process for the
council and can be avoided if residents
used the litter bins provided to dispose
of their done correctly the street scene
team will be out and about in the
district throughout October so please
come and show your support for the
campaign and spread the word
out and about clubs societies and events
rochford district health walks are held
in hullbridge on mondays at 10 45 a.m.
meet in the car park on the corner of
furry Road and paul's lane or meet at
hawk rewards on thursdays at 1045 am in
the car park which is pain display walks
are free no need to book just come along
and join in hop three scrabble club
meets at hockey day center situated in
the public car park of self their Road
hockley this well-established group
meets every tuesday evening between
six-thirty and 10pm for competitive
games and on the second and fourth
saturdays in the month from two to five
PM the social play all abilities are
catered for and the first two visits are
free so for more information contact
shirley on 0 1 702 2059 10 for more
details or just turn up rochford
district october holidays activities
program following a successful summer
lado program rochford district council
virgin active and Rochford extended
services are working in partnership on
the october holiday program information
will be available from ww watch v WK
forward slash holiday activities from
early october family theater shows at
the mill arts & Events Center in
rayleigh sunday the 13th of october at
2pm Beauty and the Beast sunday the 17th
of November at 11am and again at 2pm
offers dreamboat Sunday the twelfth of
january 2014 at 2pm the Sorcerer's
Apprentice Sunday the ninth of februari
2pm the three Billy pigs and Sunday the
ninth of March at 2pm Sally and the
sunflower all tickets are priced at only
three pounds fifty per person and to
book please phone rochford District
Council customer services on 0 1 702 318
191
braley town council will be turning on
the Christmas lights in early on
Thursday the twentieth of November at
630pm the high street will be closed to
traffic from 145 p.m. and will reopen at
8pm access to the bellingham lane car
parks is available up to 4 p.m. but
please use public transport or walk on
this very busy night we will have all
the usual attractions including singing
from our ten raleys school choirs the
mushroom theatre company there many
stalls so as you can by your presence in
time for the big day for further details
contact ray detail council's website WWE
six infonet or email plot at raley tell
council UK council and committee
meetings all meetings will take place at
the civic sweet to hockey road rail ESS
680 be and all commence at seven thirty
the review committee choose do the
eighth of october the executive
wednesday the ninth of october council
choose to the twenty-second development
committee thursday the 24th the
executive wednesday the sixth of
november the review committee tuesday
the twelfth of november development
committee thursday the 21st of november
for any further information contact
member services on 0 1 702 318 140
Maureen's gift community funding up for
grabs in rochford community groups in
the Rockford district are being invited
to apply for a share of 5000 pound
thanks to Rochford housing association
named in memory of local community
champion Maureen Vince The Moorings gift
funding scheme offers support to local
groups in need of a little financial
backing to help deliver activities in
the area Maureen's gift is now open for
applications from charities resident
groups and voluntary organizations
successful applicants are chosen by
dedicated panel of Representatives which
includes Rochford housing staff board
members and local residents Karin
Johnson Rochford housings managing
director said we know that road
these small amounts of funding can make
a real difference to people's lives
which is why Maureen's gift is so
important the funding could go towards
anything from a healthy eating project
for older people to training equipment
for young people what's important is
that the project helps people and
neighborhoods to flourish grants will be
offered to community organizations which
operate within the Rochford district I
could supply a copy of their latest
annual accounts applications from
individuals will be considered and help
is available with completing the
application form to apply contact the
Rochford housing office quoting
Maureen's gift on either o 800 131
double 348 from a landline or
oh-three-hundred one two three three
five double one from a mobile
alternatively you can email contact us
at sanctuary hyphen housing co uk and
the application process is open until
the 35th of december this year annual
report 2012-13 Rochford district council
produces an annual report which gives an
overview of the counsels performance
spending and financial position the
council produces a detailed income and
expenditure account which can be found
in a statement of accounts and is set
out in a prescribed manner the net
expenditure figures for 20-30 2012-2013
as follows making a difference to our
community which includes collection of
local taxes council tax and housing
benefits emergency planning and health
and safety leisure and sport development
housing services and homelessness
community safety elections local land
charges cemeteries and churchyards
licensing public conveniences and
democratic services the spend was five
point seven five million pounds making a
difference to our environment the mill
tower windmill woodlands park and open
spaces planning and building control
environmental health street cleansing
and recycling was five point seven three
million
making a difference to our local
community economic development and car
parks shows a small credit figure as we
received more in income from car parks
and we spent out if you take all that
into account and then deduct the
statutory accounting adjustments and so
on it gives you 10.27 net cost of local
services to be met by local and national
taxes last year meaning a 2011-12 year
we spent the following making a
difference to our community seven
million making a difference to our
environment 5.94 million making a
difference to our local community was
again a small credit figure the net cost
of services was twelve point seven three
million pounds and where did it come
from the 10.2 million pounds that we
spent on providing local services after
contributions from reserves and incomes
raised row various fees and charges came
from local and national taxes and
redistributed business rates our total
income for the year was 10.7 million
which was split point 65 million
government grants 3.19 million from
national business rates returned to the
council and 6.43 million from council
tax from residents the council is using
balances built up over previous years to
cover some of the reductions in
government funding the council
recognizes that these balances won't
last and has plans to continue to reduce
expenditure council tax the council was
responsible for collecting 48.3 million
pounds of council tax last year but we
only kept 6.43 million equivalent to 13
p in every pound collected the majority
of what's collected is paid to others as
essex county council thirty 4.4 million
pounds rocks for district council 6.3
million
Essex Police Authority 4.3 million Essex
for authority 2.1 million and perished
Town Council's 1.2 million the average
council tax for a band d property for
2012-13 was 1528 pounds 22p
discretionary rate relief charities and
some sports clubs are entitled to eighty
percent mandatory relief on their
business rates in order to provide
additional support the council panelled
discretionary relief for the remaining
twenty percent for 2012-13 discretionary
relief was awarded to 35 organizations
throughout the district at a cost to the
Council of eighteen thousand five
hundred and thirty-five pounds capital
expenditure we also spend money on
improving land and buildings in order to
continue delivering excellent cost
effective services for all our customers
capital expenditure is the money spent
on the purchase and improvement of
buildings vehicles equipment and
computer software it is called capital
expenditure as it results in assets
which the council and the community can
use for more than one year capital
expenditure does not directly affect the
council tax what we spent vehicles and
equipment 127,000 on road cemetery
extension 10,000 leisure and playing
facilities 177,000 private sector
renewal grants 32,000 disabled
facilities grants 222,000 IT
infrastructure 45,000 council properties
204,000 tens gateway energy schemes at
9,000 and the Big Society funding 11,000
which made a total of eight hundred and
thirty seven thousand some of the
projects not preceded in 2012-13 will be
rolled over into 1314 the 837 thousand
pound which was spent on our land and
property assets was paid for by capital
receipts from the sale of property
grants and from revenue how we paid for
capital expenditure in 2012-13
grants and contributions 224,000 capital
receipts 613 thousand which made the
total of eight hundred and thirty-seven
thousand delivering value for money
during 2012-13 the council has been
successful in generating income through
the provision of services to partners
and other councils and approximately
77,000 pounds has been earned from these
initiatives the council also planned to
make savings during the year of 900,000
pounds which were delivered this has
been achieved by more efficient service
and better organization rochford
district councils dedicated staff
continue to work hard to ensure it
offers its residents value for money the
council is determined to deliver high
levels of performance rochford has shown
that despite having one of the lowest
government grant funding levels it
continues to save money and reduce
spending we will continue to keep close
scrutiny over council money financial
performance rocks the District Council
is among the best in Essex and the
country when it comes to collecting
council tax the revenues and benefits
team collected 98.7 percent of the forty
eight point three million pound council
tax due last year the same as in 2011-12
we also collected 96.9 of business rates
do last year which was an increase on
2011-12 collecting income in the current
economic climate is challenging that
start have offered as much support and
advice as possible to help local
residents and businesses to pay their
bills smoke alarms save lives Aziz
County Fire and Rescue Service or EC FRS
launched a 2013 safety campaign calendar
with a monthly focus throughout October
the fire service will be encouraging
residents to ensure their family are
properly protected by fitting in testing
smoke alarms in their homes Community
Safety liaison officer for the service
Lamar quick is promoting the importance
of having a working smoke alarm in the
home that is properly fitted and
regularly tested leave said smoke alarms
provide a vital early warning at the
first sign of fire giving you and your
firmly time to gets safely get out stay
out and get the fire service out senior
divisional officer Julian Ashley added
we recommend at least one smoke alarm on
every level of your home and once those
alarms have been fitted it is important
to regularly test them to make sure that
they are fully functioning it is a great
concern that essex fire service still
attends fires at homes which do not have
a working smoke alarm leaving the
occupants that greater risk of death or
injury from a fire smoke alarms cost
just a few pounds and take minutes to
fit so there is no excuse for not making
sure that your family are properly
protected help keep yourself and your
loved ones safe in the home by following
these simple steps a working smoke alarm
can buy you valuable time to get out
stay out and call 999 make sure you fit
one on every level of your home and test
them regularly make testing your smoke
alarm part of your household routine
check the alarm by pressing the button
regularly change your battery once a
year or invest in a ten-year alarm and
clean the alarm casing twice a year to
ensure dust isn't blocking the sensor
whatever happens never remove the
battery in your smoke alarm make sure
that everyone in your home knows what to
do in a fire and practice your escape
route to arrange a free home fire safety
visit from Essex County Fire and Rescue
Service you can call them on 0845 60
12495 or email webmaster at essex hyphen
fire golf dot uk' help combat loneliness
become a befriender in our modern and
fast-paced society some individuals find
themselves left behind through no fault
of their own they gradually become more
and more isolated no one to visit no one
to crawl days can turn into weeks
without any contact with the outside
world the refunding scheme led by a
class appoint association of voluntary
services
is an initiative operating within the
castle point and Rochford Railly areas
to combat isolation and loneliness the
service helps change the lives of many
residents by pairing them with a trained
volunteer befriender to provide
companionship and support a cup of tea
or walked the shops or a trip out just
once a week can make a huge difference
to somebody's life this popular scheme
relies on volunteers so if you could
spare just one hour a week and would
like to make a real difference to
someone's life please contact in the
rayleigh Rochford area anne-marie
fordham on 0 1 2 68 638 416 or 0 7 97 99
1 4 7 4 3 you can email an dot-marie
fordham at castle point AVS org dot UK
and in the castle point area beverly
parish on 0126 863 8 for 16 or 0779 for
515 609 you can email Beverly dot parish
that's parish with 2 r's at castle point
AVS org dot uk' how safe is your home
essex county council Trading Standards
in partnership with Rochford District
Council's community safety team funded
and delivered one day free home safety
checks for residents in the district
following the success of the Trading
Standards pilot safe home save lives
project in tendering and castle point in
2011 the initiative was expanded and is
currently being delivered in a number of
local authority areas of cross Essex
residents eligible for the scheme were
visited by trading standards officers
wear portable appliance testing known as
pat was carried out for free on their
small appliances any appliance or
equipment which failed the Pat
were repaired or replaced free of charge
this was to ensure residents were not
left without essential appliances
residents were also provided with advice
on dealing cold calling and using the
fire with confidence scheme to find
reputable traders Lindsay yarnall the
ECC Trading Standards officer said I am
pleased to have had the opportunity to
deliver the checks in rochford district
one of the main aims that the initiative
is to ensure the safety of older adults
living independently in doing this we
are reducing the risk of risk of
domestic accidents and fires the physics
give us the opportunity to give advice
around doorstep crime and consider wider
safeguarding issues the checks are
particularly important and give peace of
mind for older and vulnerable residents
Rochford district matters is designed
and published by rockford district
council its editor is lianna marie green
the telephone number for the council is
0 1 702 546 366 and the magazine is
printed by Morton print limited 01 50 75
2 3 4 5 6 this recording has been
produced by volunteers from the rayleigh
Rochford and castle point talking
newspaper for the blind